[Musique]
quand on achète des biens d'occasion
directement de particulier comment se
protéger le nombre de consommateurs
ouverts à l'économie de seconde main à
plus que doublé depuis 2016 sur des
plateformes comme Kijiji ou Marketplace
l'offre de produits est infini et cela
nous met en contact avec toutes sortes
de gens il peut être imprudent de
conclure une transaction chez soi avec
quelqu'un qu'on ne connaît pas mieux
vaut se déplacer en terrain neutre
sachez que plusieurs villes mettent à la
disposition des citoyens des zones
d'échanges sécurisées ou sur neutre des
endroits publics éclairés surveillés par
caméra 24 heures sur 24 séjour sur 7 et
souvent situé à côté d'un poste de
police le commandant Steve Belzil du
SPVM conseille aussi d'être accompagné
c'est plus prudent mais selon lui le
simple fait de proposer un tel lieu de
rencontre décourage les fraudeurs qui
vont renoncer à se présenter bref quand
vous transigez
côté de vous faire déculotter et pensez
à vous protéger passez le mot
[Musique]